what do you think is the most essential
ingredient for plant survival think
about it yes it's water water is
essential without water plants wouldn't
be able to bloom protect fruits or grow
seeds they even need to absorb nutrients
and minerals through their Roots do you
know that 90% of plant's body is made of
water yes and water helps seeds sprout
dissolve nutrients to move them around
and it even protects the crop from
extreme
temperatures and how do we ensure plants
get all this water through irrigation
now you may ask what is
irrigation simply put irrigation is a
process of watering crops just watering
crops then why do we need such a fancy
name like irrigation for just watering
crops well it's not just watering crops
it's about watering them at the right
time and in the right amount to help
them grow and stay productive
naturally the next question is what
determines this right time and right
amount yes what determines the right
time and the right amount depends on few
important factors like the type of crop
different plants need different amounts
of water for example Patty needs way
more water than
wheat soil type or the type of soil
matters a lot sandy soil for instance
dries out quickly and needs more free
beon watering while clay soils hold
water for longer then season hot summer
days means plants lose more water due to
evaporation and transpiration so they
need extra Care on the other hand during
monsoon nature does most of the watering
for us so the need of irrigation is much
less during
monsoon so watering crops at the right
time in the right amount based on
factors like type of crop soil and
season is what we call irrigation
and without proper irrigation plant can
W and let's be honest none of us want
our fields and plants to look like this
the next big question is where does
irrigation water come from or in other
words what are the sources of water for
irrigation irrigation water can come
from a variety of sources it can be
extracted from groundw which is drawn
from Wells tube Wells or water spring or
it can come from surface water uh like
rivers lakes and canals there are also
some pretty Innovative sources such as
non-conventional sources which includes
rainwater harvested or treated drainage
water which is reused for watering
crops now how exactly is water extracted
from these different sources and
diverted to the Farmland well Farmers
usually rely on two main methods the
traditional method and the modern
technique back in the day irrigation
involved all some pretty basic yet
clever techniques these methods were
simple often relying on human or animal
effort let's take a quick look at some
of them the first and probably the most
common one is a police system you might
have seen this in action before it is
where water is lifted using a pulley and
now exactly what is a pulley a pulley is
a mechanical device as you can see here
which is designed to reduce the effort
needed to pull something heavy like a
bucket of water from a well as you see
here it's a very smart technique right
yes it
is next up we have a rotating chain pump
system this system uses a rotating chain
to bring water to the surface as you can
imagine or as you see in this diagram
the chain rotates and as it does it
Scoops up water perhaps from a well or
even a river and bring it to the top
where it's needed from there it is
diverted to the farmland and how is this
rotated usually this is again rotated by
using a human effort or maybe an animal
effort is being used in rotating These
Chains then there is liver system think
of it as like a long lver used to scoop
water it works just like a seesaw
balancing the weight of the water on one
side and the effort either Again by
human or animal on the other it is very
simple and effective
technique and finally we have Furrow
irrigation which you might have seen
many times where water flows through
these trenes dug in the field these
trenes guide the water directly to the
crops making sure they stay
hydrated while these traditional methods
were cheap and easy to set up they
weren't the most efficient at saving
water or covering large
areas but hey they got the job done for
centuries you got to admire
simple clever methods they laid the
foundation for modern irrigation system
we use today fast forward to today an
irrigation has gone high-tech modern
system focuses on saving water while
still getting the job done let explore
two of the methods here the first is a
sprinkler irrigation or a sprinkler
system in this method pipes with nozzles
spray water like rain over a large area
it works well with uneven surfaces
ensuring that every corner gets just the
right amount of
water now where does the water come from
for the sprinkler system water is pumped
from River well or other sources using a
motorized
pump next up is drip irrigation and in
this method water is directly delivered
to the root drop by drop there is no
wastage here it's super precise this
method is a lifesaver in water scarce
areas as it ensures that every drop
counts just like with the sprinkler
irrigation the water is pumped from a
river or a well using a motorized pump
so in modern irrigation techniques human
or animal effort has been replaced by
machines like motorized pump these
advancements not only save time and
energy but makes irrigation far more
efficient and sustainable
so let's quickly summarize so what is
irrigation it's just watering crops at
the right time and in the right amount
simple right factors like type of crop
soil and season decide how much water is
needed and what are the sources of water
in for irrigation irrigation water comes
from groundwater like Well Spring tube
Wells Etc surface water like rivers
lakes and canals and then you have some
non-conventional sources like rain water
or even tree heed drainage water now to
distribute this water farmers use
traditional and mod modern methods
traditional methods rely on human or
animal effort and the first one is the
most common type that is a pulley system
which lifts water using a pulley to
reduce
effort the second method is a chain pump
method where rotating chain scoop water
to the surface and the third one is a
liver system works like a sea sort of
scoop water
water fourth traditional method is fur
irrigation where trenches guide water to
the
crops traditional methods are cheap and
simple but they are not so
efficient now the mo modern methods are
machine driven and saves a lot of water
first one being sprinkler irrigation
where pipes spray water like rain
perfect for uneven land then you have
drip irrigation where
which delivers water drop by drop to the
plant roots ideal for water scarse areas
both the modern methods use motorized
pump replacing human or animal effort
with these techniques farming is faster
smarter and way more sustainable